Let's look at the code that I wrote to do this. Here's all that stuff that we
had to do just to make the computer happy. And then here's the interesting
part. I wanted to print on two lines, so I used system out print line twice. On
the first line, I wanted to print hello, so I put hello in quotes. And I passed
it out to system out print By putting it in the parentheses. On the second
line, I want it to print out world, so I write world in quotes and again, put
it in the parentheses. To run this in the Udacity IDE, I just copy this. I'm
going to use Cmd+C or Ctrl+C depending on whether I'm on a Mac or a PC. And
then I'm going to go to the Udacity IDE and I'm going to paste it in. Now I can
test run it. And like I expected it prints hello and world on separate lines.